[Music]
ariana is joining us now in los angeles
how can we help
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call
um
i finished grad school at the end of
2019
and um with about 71 000 in student
loans from that degree
and when covet happened and the interest
got paused and payments got paused i
really didn't make any payments but i've
still been saving money and as of a
couple days ago i have the money in my
account to pay off
that entire loan wow good for you
what's your degree in
thank you it's in consumer psychology
and i'm kind of doing something related
to it but uh consumer psychology is
depressing isn't it
it is it is it's really depressing what
is because i think there's other people
listening that want to know details what
is consumer psychology it's one of my
favorites you you you explain it's one
of my favorite things but you explain it
on you that you're the expert
yeah sure well my degrees in implied
psychology and there was a focus on
consumer psychology so it's just
understanding the motivations of why
people make the decisions what they do
when they're purchasing but
i'm actually in kind of a
a different field went into something
different just because yes it was
depressing and it did not uh is it
depressing because is it depressing
because uh you now see uh how pathetic
humans are and how easily manipulated
manipulated they are to buy something
what's going on much much less free will
than we like to walk around believing
there is that's what i was thinking and
people make decisions based on
tribes not on rational thinking all
right is that fair ariana does describe
your graduate degree
yes
all right sorry i i was learning on
behalf of the audience so
why wouldn't you pay off the student
loans now because you have the money in
full why wouldn't you do right
i'm pretty confident that i'm going to
do that i've just been getting a lot of
conflicting advice from my parents and
financial planners that are kind of
advising
to buy a home instead or involved
instead
just because they know i have that money
right now um because they're okay with
that can i talk to a real psychologist
for a second
yes okay so you know one of the core
tenets
of psychology one of the core tenets of
a person being
physiologically and psychologically well
is this idea of autonomy i have some say
however limited that might be i have
some limited control in what my tomorrow
might look like
and i have come to believe
that when you are in debt to somebody
else to an institution to a group to a
vehicle loan whatever that may be
that you limit your autonomy for
tomorrow and i've come to believe that
you cannot be psychologically whole if
you owe somebody else something if
somebody else is dictating your tomorrow
actions because of something you bought
yesterday
is that fair
yeah and i agree i think having a home
is so incredible oh so cool having your
own place
but if you pay this off you will wake up
tomorrow and go you know what i can do
anything i want because i owe nobody
that's right and you will get an awesome
home but now you have a lot less stress
and you're going to be wealthy
yeah stop listening to other people what
advice would you give you're this is fun
i got two psychologists in here what
advice she's a real one i'm a pretend
one i'm a podcast host she's a real
psychologist i was trying to be nice to
you okay it's fair so what would you
ariana what would you say to you
seriously step out of the situation what
advice would you give you you want to
pay this off that's what you said and
you're getting conflicting advice
meaning opposite of what you want to do
parents and some goofball financial
advisor who's an idiot is telling you
something different what would you tell
yourself
um to trust my gut here and what i'm
hearing right now definitely solve for
freedom
you will wake up tomorrow free
free
ash i wish you could do it right now can
we pay it off while you're on the air we
got a minute and a half is it all set up
well i guess
i guess that's my
my next question would i would you guys
advise i just empty my account
uh yeah i think you're saying that the
wrong way would we advise that you pay
all this student loan off right right
now
because you have all of the money to do
it yes we would if that's the question
yes
and it will take you okay you're right
it'll take you three months four months
to have a fully funded emergency fund
and then you think you know what freedom
is until you have no payments and a
fully funded emergency fund
and that's when the call is going to
come to say hey can you move to this
state for this particular job and you're
going to be able to laugh and go yeah
i'll be there tomorrow because right
that's right and i love that you said
that doc because ariana the next thing
is you begin to focus on what is it that
you really want to do with your life in
every area
you're completely unchained
professionally
financially you're you're free john's
exactly right what are you waiting on
i'm hanging up on you right now you're
done
i didn't actually hang up on her we put
her on hold we never hang up on anybody
unless you're a jerk but here's the deal
it's time we just set one person free
ken coleman well we didn't do it she did
she's ready for her hard work very
honest set yourself free like right now
like go do it right now what are you
waiting on